en este vídeo quiero ver un montón de
ejemplos de los dos tipos de
multiplicaciones de binomios que te vas
a encontrar más frecuentemente en
álgebra el primero es elevar al cuadrado
por ejemplo que nos pidan determinar
algo de la forma x más 9 y eso elevado
al cuadrado
la primer tentación es decir que esto es
igual a x al cuadrado más 9 al cuadrado
pero esto está mal no hay que caer en
esa tentación déjame quitarlo vale
entonces no es igual a eso para saber
que es igual tenemos que acordarnos que
quiere decir elevar algo al cuadrado y
simplemente es multiplicar en este caso
este binomio por sí mismo por x + 9 va
esto de aquí ya lo podemos desarrollar
para ver qué nos queda déjame hacerlo lo
voy a hacer con multiplicación larga
entonces aquí voy a poner x + 9 y aquí
abajo voy a multiplicar por x + 9 lo voy
a poner
así con colores para poder ir siguiendo
cada término vale
y entonces hacemos la multiplicación
primero empezamos con este 99 por 9 81
81 9 por equis es 9 x luego vamos con la
x x por 9 también es 9 x y x x x x al
cuadrado x al cuadrado entonces el
resultado el resultado de hacer la
multiplicación sería x al cuadrado y x
al cuadrado no voy a poner con otro
color sería x al cuadrado más 18 x 18 x
+ 81 creo que aquí más o menos se ve un
patrón verdad hoy le voy a poner aquí
que es igual a x al cuadrado más 18 x
más 81 entonces ahorita te voy a decir
exactamente cuál es el patrón pero vamos
a pensarlo tantito o sea que es lo que
sucedió que apareció pues me apareció el
x al cuadrado que viene de multiplicar
esta x con esta x aparece el 81 que
viene de multiplicar los nueves y allí y
además aparece este 18 x y de dónde vino
pues vino de este 9 x y este 9 x que
eran igualitos verdad entonces sumando 9
x con 9
nos quedó igual a 18 x va vamos a
hacerlo un poco más en general para ver
realmente cómo es el patrón entonces
déjame poner que queremos determinar
x + b x + b al cuadrado donde ve donde
vamos a pensar la horita como constante
vale como en este ejemplo de acá solo
que es cualquier constante bueno vamos a
realizar la multiplicación para ver que
nos queda a ver la voy a poner por acá x
+ b x x + y en color verde b b
ok entonces que nos queda
b por vez b cuadrada b por x es x b lo
voy a poner así xb vale luego x por b
también es x b y x x x x al cuadrado
entonces la respuesta para esta
multiplicación es x al cuadrado más aquí
tenemos 2x vez más 2 x b más b al
cuadrado vale entonces ve aquí ya se ve
clarísimo clarísimo en qué consiste
elevar al cuadrado un binomio exponer el
primer término al cuadrado luego dos
veces el producto de ambos términos y
finalmente el segundo término al
cuadrado vamos a ver algunos ejemplos
más para agarrar práctica vale
imagínate que queremos que queremos
encontrar 3x menos 73 x menos 7 al
cuadrado como le haríamos pues bueno
vamos a utilizar la formulita el primero
al cuadrado más dos veces el primero por
el segundo más el segundo al cuadrado
bueno ahí ya sonaba que estamos haciendo
memorización verdad está bueno para
velocidad pero
es bueno siempre es bueno tener en
cuenta ese tipo es de donde viene que
viene de utilizar la propiedad
distributiva pero bueno vamos a hacerlo
vamos a ver qué nos queda sería el
primero al cuadrado
el primero es 3 x 3 x al cuadrado
luego más dos veces el primer término
por el segundo el primero es 3 x 3 x y
luego estamos sumando un -7 bueno
estamos restando un 7 pero eso es lo
mismo que sumar un -7 para entonces es
por menos 7 y luego sumamos menos 7 al
cuadrado menos 7 al cuadrado vamos a ver
cuánto nos queda
simplificando 3x al cuadrado pues
utilizando leyes de los exponentes y así
sería 9 x al cuadrado más 2 por 13 6 6
por 7 42 pero aquí hay un menos entonces
más bien debía haber puesto menos 42 x y
luego hay que sumar menos 7 al cuadrado
que es 49 49 para entonces nos quedan 9
x al cuadrado menos 42 x 49 y bueno este
fue un método un poco más rápido déjame
verificarlo con la división larga
tradicional para ver qué día de
veracidad es lo voy a poner por acá 3 x
menos 7
otra vez en colores le voy a poner 3 x
entonces vamos a hacerlo también así
para ver qué nos queda exactamente lo
mismo menos 7 x menos 7 es más 49 luego
menos 7 por 3x es menos 21 x ok luego
vamos con el morado 3 x con menos 7 es
menos 21 x y finalmente 3x multiplicado
con 3x pues es 9 x al cuadrado vamos a
ver qué nos queda sumando estos dos nos
debería dar lo mismo aquí es 9 x al
cuadrado menos 42 x más 49 y si si da
exactamente lo mismo verdad muy bien
vamos a hacer vamos a hacer uno más para
agarrar así mucha práctica ahora lo
vamos a hacer con un poquito más de
variables déjame ponerlo de este lado
de este lado imagínate que nos piden
encontrar 4 x al cuadrado más me voy a
poner aquí un cuadrado elevado al
cuadrado es exactamente la misma idea
que en los ejemplos anteriores tenemos
que tomar el primero y elevarlo al
cuadrado sería 4x al cuadrado elevado al
cuadrado más dos veces 4x cuadrada
porque cuadrada
es el producto de los dos dos veces más
el segundo ya cuadrada elevado al
cuadrado muy bien vamos a ver qué nos
queda simplificando esto es igual a 4 al
cuadrado es 16 x al cuadrado es x al
cuadrado al cuadrado es quizá la cuarta
entonces es 16 x a la cuarta más 2 x 4
es 8x cuadrada ye cuadrada
x cuadrada y cuadrada más he cuadrado al
cuadrado más que a la cuarta y a la
cuarta
muy bien entonces ya sabemos elevar un
binomio al cuadrado ya somos expertos
ahora vamos a pasar a otro tipo de
producto especial que tiene que ver con
multiplicar la suma de dos números con
su resta y estoy aquí sale muy bonito
déjame hacerlo en general
imagínate que nos piden de hacer la
multiplicación a más ve a más ve por a
menos b
entonces es la suma de dos números
multiplicada con su resta entonces
déjame ver qué nos queda vamos a hacerlo
multiplicando cada uno de los términos
va entonces sería a por éste a sería a
él a morado por el a verde luego a por
este menos b entonces aquí va con menos
y sería
ve
luego ve con este a aquí es más entonces
sería más ve
y finalmente tenemos que restar de
morado con be verde vale de morado con
verde pero esto de los colores es nada
más medio artificial verdad para poder
ir siguiendo en realidad podemos
simplificar la expresión que nos
quedaría ya simplificada pues eso sería
igual a déjame ponerlo con este color
azul bonito
entonces igual a aquí tenemos a por ice
a cuadrada luego menos ave es menos
luego más vea pues lo voy a poner como
más ave nada más cambia el orden de los
factores menos b por b - b cuadrada y
entonces reescribiendo esto bueno
simplificando podemos cancelar este ave
con este ave porque aquí tiene signo
menos y nos queda igual a cuadrada menos
b cuadrada y esto está bien bonito
porque simplifica las cosas en muchos
casos vamos a hacer un ejemplo vamos a
hacer un ejemplo de esto
imagínate que nos piden multiplicar 2 x
1 con 2 x 1 con 2 x + 1 entonces bueno
aquí puse primero la resta éste lo
podemos pensar como a menos b éste lo
podemos pensar como a hamás ve entonces
a es 2 x b es 1 y entonces nos queda
igual a igual
igual a al cuadrado o sea 2x al cuadrado
menos b al cuadrado ves 1 entonces es
menos 1 al cuadrado que es igual a 4 x
al cuadrado menos 1 muy bien nada más
vamos a hacer un último ejemplo con un
poquito más de variables para ver qué es
exactamente lo mismo
imagínate que nos piden la
multiplicación 5 a menos 2 b con 5 a + 2
b
una vez más es la suma de dos números
por la diferencia eso es súper
importante que estemos en ese caso sí
como vimos arriba un binomio al cuadrado
se hace de otra forma y multiplicar
otros binomios también pero ahorita
tenemos que hacerlo con la suma y la
resta siempre en la duda es mejor
utilizar la propiedad distributiva saleh
pero bueno ahorita si aplica es más ve
por a menos b y entonces nos quedaría
igual
el primero al cuadrado 25 a al cuadrado
bueno déjame ponerlo paso a paso
entonces 5 a al cuadrado menos el
segundo al cuadrado menos 2 b al
cuadrado y esto nos queda igual a 25 a
cuadrada
- 4 b cuadrado muy bien voy a dejarle
hasta aquí en este vídeo nos vemos hasta
la próxima